i've just received like some dms from
like people that i never thought in a
million years would
be getting dms from so yeah some some
exciting collabs may be
coming
[Music]
let's take it from the top so you put
out this internet drama part one
how did this idea start and where where
did you find the posts
um yeah so i've been making music for a
long time
i've always been into production and
songwriting and uh
and uh and then like recently i've just
been like really into tick-tock i just
love watching videos on there
and i was thinking like yeah like maybe
i should uh i should try
and make some tick tocks and so i
started making a few
and i was kind of um researching kind of
looking at
what's working what other musicians are
doing and just in general like what what
people want to see on tiktok and how
how the platform works and uh and so i
was like had that brewing for a few days
and then i kind of thought like oh yeah
okay like how funny would it be
to take something really really silly
like an argument on the internet and
then spend
days trying to craft something beautiful
around it and so that's where it came
from
it's so good i mean the the work that
went into it because i was all
like i was like the song's really good
but like the music video is like a
full-on production
um shot so well edited so well how long
does this process take you from
finding the uh internet beef to the
fruition
so finding them is actually really
tricky it's harder than i expected
um and then once i found it like because
you need like a specific vibe like it
can't be too harsh or else it won't be
fun
it's got to be funny it's gotta have but
anyway uh and then once i find that
and i sit down uh i start trying to come
up with the melody
um and kind of kind of make myself laugh
with trying to find the part the part
that i think will be most important
like make myself laugh with it and then
um
and then another day to like flesh out
the production
and then another day to like record the
vocals and harmonies and then
to mix and then uh storyboarding and
then
shooting and editing so totally it's
like five to seven days
wow so do you do you change these
people's names because like
i feel like they're like these people
from these beefs since it's gotten so
big have got to like reveal themselves
at some points
i can't stop thinking about helen and
caroline like someone has to know them
in this long-standing broccoli casserole
recipe feud
right well actually what's funny is uh
one of the first
interviews that i did was buzzfeed uh
david mack
went and tracked them down and
discovered that they were
parody accounts um and but they had made
real facebook accounts and they were
pretending to be other people and i
guess that's against the rules
so their accounts got deleted um and
that's why i couldn't find them because
i didn't know where it was from either
but yeah oh my gosh i i i can't stop
thinking about like the
the keep your name out of my thin mouth
is the funniest insult
i've heard in a long time and then the
butter one
i'm like between 2 and 4am
yeah yeah i think my partner found that
one um
and it's just so funny i mean just but
it's so relatable too there's like
something about that like
you just need this thing you don't want
to talk to anybody you don't want to
meet ah come on you know like i just
want the butter
please you know yeah i don't want to
meet people i don't want new friends no
i just need butter
so the first song you you made it you
produced it
uploaded to tick tock and then what
happened did you go to bed and then you
wake up the next day and you're like oh
my god
what happened um well what's crazy is
like
i mean like i'm a little addicted to the
stats and stuff and so
i was immediately like how's it doing
how's it doing and um
because i had had one video do like a
hundred thousand views i was kind of
like
that was my goal i was like oh that
would be cool and in the first two hours
it did 270
000 and so i was like okay and then in
another hour it had hit a million
and then in another hour had done
another million and that's when i was
like
what have i done like this is crazy uh
yeah
no it was wild and then obviously went
to bed woke up the next day to like 9
million or something
and i was like okay yeah i think i want
to say the first two were out before it
was new year's eve
i'm obviously at home just hanging out
but that was like my jam new year's eve
was i was just listening to that song
over and over again just bring it in
2021
being live thanks
[Laughter]
so do you do you plan to keep up the
internet drama songs is there a part
five
in the works um i haven't started on a
new one yet
so that's but uh but i definitely plan
to do more
i mean uh people love them and uh what i
didn't realize
when i was first making them is like how
much they mean to people
so i i think like that's just like mo
like some people are just going through
a tough time and they're telling me like
this was like
i made me laugh and brought a smile to
my face and so it's like okay these
matter
and so that's kind of motivating to feel
like it like it matters to people
so i definitely am going to keep doing
them until i either get sick of them or
they just stop working
but i also want to do more concepts and
try different ideas i don't know if
anything will work quite like this but
um but yeah
yeah i know i've seen a lot of people
like suggesting things like i even
tweeted that i was interviewing you and
people were like oh you should tell him
to do
this or tell him to do that so i'm sure
you're getting a lot of um
feedback and suggestions absolutely and
like
there's some good ones in there um a lot
of them are
it's it's just tough to find ones that
work well right like
yeah sometimes it's just like a regular
conversation and i don't think this is
gonna be funny
but yeah right so you're obviously doing
the lord's work
is there like what's the pressure like
to keep delivering these
um yeah that's funny i mean like after
the first one
i felt a lot of pressure because i was
like if i can do this again
this could be something like i did not
think it would be this
but i i was like okay so and then i was
like you know and if i can do two
then the pressure's off right no i was
completely wrong
um the pressure is more odd than ever
but
there's still so much fun to do and i
try to just like focus on that
um but it is weird because like the
first one i was just brainstorming
and it was just to come up with an idea
but now there's this context of like
millions of people
will see it and it's like yeah it's very
weird i'm getting used to it
it's funny because the first one drops
and i'm like this is so funny i'm like
cracking up and the second one drops
and you have that what did caroline do
happen like greek chorus moment and then
the beat drops and i'm like oh my god
this is like a fog i mean
i saw that you uploaded them to spotify
or streaming which is fantastic
would you do like a full length internet
drama
album like i guess it might just end up
becoming one over time
yeah i i know people like ask also for
like longer versions of the songs
but i really like keeping them short it
already takes me like
five to seven days to make one and you
never know if it's gonna work like even
like
i could tomorrow that's like the nature
of tick tock right is it
doesn't matter who you are it's like i
could post one tomorrow that flops and
so
uh i like to keep it tight so that it's
like
yeah i don't know i was thinking about
this a lot last night i was digging into
the grammy rules and i really feel like
you could win like a best comedy album
situation off of this because
all you need to do is have like 30
minutes in songs it doesn't matter the
track length and you have to have them
on streaming
i really think you can do this oh my god
how silly would that be how ridiculous
it would be so well deserved the
the the work that goes into this i mean
it's oh my god
thank you thank you
[Music]
we put them on spotify but i'm like it's
kind of weird without the visual like
to me it's like is it clear that there's
two different characters because i
didn't really change my voice
but people seem to be vibing to them i
don't know the streams are
they're stacking up i feel like it's
it's the people that are because like
i do think like your acting brings it to
life
even more because it's like the
expressions are so funny
um so what goes into these videos are
you wearing you're wearing your
partner's clothes or like what's what's
going on here
yeah i mean uh we we uh we shoot them
together
um and yeah we're just trying to like
it's always like you're trying to find
something that
um is a like each shot's got to be
simple
and have like a clear idea kind of like
a pop song
the vocal is up front and there's
nothing getting in the way everything's
just supporting
and then we also try to like weave in
details
um for people to pick up for like the
re-watchability
and uh and it's that's really fun
because then people notice them in the
comments and kind of it like shows us to
like keep
keep putting more details yes um yeah
the the butter hair flip like outside in
the snow
gets me every time i like cry laugh
every time
that was my partner's idea she was like
uh it's she's like it's gonna snow
we gotta shoot this day it's gonna snow
like crazy
so yeah amazing partner great great
advice
so i feel like the these songs obviously
speak to just how amazing
of an artist you are and you dropped
long text recently
and i felt like a little bit of shift in
your sound like i've listened to a lot
of your sound but this one felt closer
to kind of this internet drama like
poppy vibe are you kind of leaning into
that
sound a little more yeah well i was
already kind of moving in that direction
in the stuff that i was working on that
i hadn't released yet
um so yeah there's a bunch of stuff
lined up that is
like it's still weird like it's more
weird almost then like
like in the tik toks i'm trying to do
like a straight pop sound because i feel
like the content is already weird enough
um but then for the for the music i
wanted to be kind of a little weird but
just more accessible than the stuff i
was doing before
so i think it's going to bridge the gap
kind of between
the like more experimental stuff i had
out and the like
super pop tick tocks yeah yeah so what
has the internet drama songs done
for your your other music like how big
of a change in streams fans
listeners what's it been like um i mean
the the ratio
from before to now is basically all of
them like it like more like practically
you know like
everyone everything is is from here on
it like um
i don't remember what the streams were i
mean you know what don't know did well
it had like 100
000 streams but i don't know what it's
at now but it's like it's gone
way beyond that and uh yeah it's it's
like fun
too because people are coming from the
internet drama
going to the like the what i call my
less funny music
and leaving comments like i found you
through this and but i love this and
this song means a lot to me and whatever
so yeah it's really fun
yeah i've noticed a lot of the comments
are like yeah this is good you guys need
to check out his other music too like if
you like this so yeah it's definitely
worth i love how there's people out
there like you know
somebody will like leave a comment like
oh does he have other music and then
someone be like yes search him on
spotify or whatever like there's people
like helping
it's super cool so yesterday i posted i
was interviewing you and i
i don't think i've ever gotten a bigger
response for i'm interviewing this
person tomorrow
um but a lot like there was a couple
people that were like i don't know who
this is and i was like oh
i wish i could watch this for the first
time again here you go
and they all came back like oh my god
i'm dead right now
that's amazing that's so fun so what do
you want people to know
about your i don't even i don't want to
really differentiate
them too much but like your less funny
music i guess we'll call it
yeah i'm trying to
[Music]
do stuff that i find exciting
um or that i find fun like i'm trying to
experiment
uh i'm trying to you know pull different
inspirations and mash them together
and uh and and there's like a bunch of
really cool stuff lined up in like
various stages of completion that like i
haven't been able to work on in a while
obviously that i'm like excited to get
back to
um and yeah i'm just like i'm just
excited to
bring that stuff out like parallel to uh
to more internet dramas
you're in the middle of this kind of
momentum so is there a pressure that
you're feeling to kind of
ride this wave and like put out more
music like
how do you feel yeah i mean we we kind
of rushed to put out this song
it was like the it was crazy how like
perfectly like topical it was
um and it was like the one that was
closest to being done and so we like
finished that up and put it out so that
we could like
you know ride this wave um there's a lot
of pressure also to just like make more
content and
and i think um uh there there's like uh
when when i i think and i could be wrong
but i think that part of what's working
is the amount of
attention to detail and how like hard we
work on the content to make it really
interesting and fun and tight
um and so it takes a lot of time and so
we can't just do the like quick
kind of like what's up so that's like
tough
uh and yeah just like hard to find time
to be creative now how has your partner
your friends your family responded to
this kind of
blow up that you're having right now uh
they are all
thrilled my mom is like through the roof
uh she watches every interview
she's like you gotta send me all the
links you gotta tell me when it's gonna
be on and i'm like
i don't know i'm gonna try um yeah
everyone's just so excited
and uh and it's really nice yeah i feel
like everyone
like a bunch of celebs have seen your
videos and music
who were you the most starstruck by that
was like oh this is great or retweeted
it or shared it or whatever
i mean it's hard to say i think there's
just been so many crazy things i mean
the first one was like i didn't even
remember i had a twitter account until
jermaine from flight of the concords
retweeted one of them and i was like no
way like
um uh apparently dion warwick
uh joined tick tock because of me like i
don't know
what is going on here um like obviously
like jimmy fallon allison bree that was
like
thrilling there's like a comment from
dan harmon on alison brees post that
he was like it was something like i'm in
an optometrist right now so listening
without volume but it's already funny
i was like wow that's crazy i've
definitely had my day of like blue
cheese has
mold in it all day blue cheese
i don't know like yeah and i've just
received like some dms from like people
that i never thought in a million years
would
be getting dms from so yeah some some
exciting collabs may be
coming that was my next question do you
ha is there a possible
collab happening somewhere yeah there's
some possible ones it's
tough for the internet drama format i
thought it would be easier
um but we need to like i i need some
time to just like find
more good multi-character content
um because because i think that's like a
great angle
um but uh but just in music in general
like i've seen like doors open up and so
i'm just excited to see what i can do
like i i i was like
i want to do cool with cool people so
and that seems like it's more possible
than ever so yeah
well who's your who's your top like
dream collab like let's put it in the
universe
um i saw i i wouldn't like put anyone at
the top there's like there's like an
infinite list and like
i i've been kind of trying to think and
i always feel like we're going to end
this interview and i'm going to think of
30 more people in which i
said uh i've been saying i guess like uh
caroline policek i'm like a little bit
obsessed with right now
i love her melodies i think the stuff
she's doing is incredible
and also um childish gambino like does
like such cool stuff his tv show is
amazing
or like donald glover like his tv show
is amazing his music's amazing and that
would be super cool but yeah there's
like
there's a laundry list yeah right right
you're a force i mean i'm like this guy
could be an actor he could be a director
he could be a
photographer he could be a songwriter he
could be a singer like whatever you want
to do
this is lublin's world we're just living
in it you are so fantastic to talk to um
so thank you people are watching this
where where should we send them where
should we go to listen to your music um
so you can go to
uh lubell.in l-u-b-a-l dot i-n
and all the links are there or you can
search lublin on
spotify apple music wherever you stream
youtube
instagram twitter tiktok
[Music]
obviously
you